what's up gamers it's me
I've been kicked out of my house might
citizen let me stay in my office anymore
because I've been playing World of Tanks
that's my only world sorry March say
you're not my world anymore it's all
about the World of Tanks
you guys should sign up for this this
has been a setup this sponsorship with
World of Tanks has been a setup by bunch
media I knew it how do I get rid of this
get rid of it oh I just click there what
I have is not this measly little [ __ ]
okay
what I have is what I call bet done
that's right Swedish tanked Swedish
steel hard as a diamond rock our command
is called hit by copter all cooked
Korean and 3s all and Captain feel
excuse me
let's go okay here we go here we go oh
god oh god oh god Beth Anne is ringing
out Oh God
Oh the bet that doesn't have a moving
head I didn't realize that that's
interesting this is such a cool tank
this reminds me of every day in Sweden
going to school with my tank so far I
have done absolutely nothing for the
team that's how Swedish people do it in
Wars this is a cool map though am i
driving on eyes with a freaking tank oh
god here we go here we go here we go
show yourself show yourself coward
show yourself okay all right we've taken
many damages we've taken many damages
it's fine it's fine show yourself
look at that renegade is crying because
he's so bad what the sweets will rise
again don't worry I have no choice but
to replace Batman okay let's get this
one oh dude my tank fartin that's epic
that's okay we'll follow BC 12 he looks
watch out
Panther huh evil shoot him oh sorry just
making sure come on I gotta prove myself
I gotta get that first kill someone
shoot Leo birthday Oh what the hell Oh
God
all this bad this bad I take it I've
taken a critical damage oh they hit my
treadmill that's right I can still shoot
can someone help me okay all right got a
good feeling about this one we're going
for the flank this time oh god they got
graphics cards oh god they got many
graphics cards all right we're gonna
flank ay ay ay ay
stop this is stop stop who shoot to me
okay I will get my first kill I need one
kill for this video I'm looking at you
[Music]
he's almost dead huh
I can see him this could be my first kid
Keith come on come on cool no no no no I
just want to apologize in advance to all
my teammates can I go up the mountain oh
yeah oh god he missed fine
oh wow we did it see it pays off to do
nothing in war take it from the Swedes I
will accept the benefits I did work hard
I survived I survived god damn it fine
we're fine this happens all the time I
made it I'm alive
surprise mother got him I knew I was
good at game I knew I was good at game
there in the houses how can tanks 15
houses watch we're gonna flank him we're
gonna flank him
wash wash we're gonna flank him why is
that a ramp fine sure can i play with
the room fine sure well I get banned am
i okay to play this is that illegal
listen it's for the holiday season okay
Oh glorious ropes now Shay
Oh glorious don't push now said look at
the rooms now say I got a great feeling
about rooms now say hey stop that
oh god rooms I didn't do good in uphills
we have found that was nerve wrecking
uphill of all time come on
rubbish now say oh we don't do uphills
any day now
locking on target finish now sir oh yes
did you get him damn nope
cheese says do something it's fine it's
fine it's fine it's fine damn nice shop
yeah yes come on no no no no all right
we're going in
are you just comparing sizes yes Chris
goose is bigger doesn't mean it's better
now God uphill spankings now sins
biggest weakness he does not do up hills
all right we wait what they see bush
what you really are
tank oh it's okay
Rick why does it always ricocheting not
like this not like this
Oh students nothing got you right where
I want you got your right all right yeah
get the Stu shin Oh God
you can hide but you can't do shin it's
nice and this is my girl no one's gonna
take him where is he always hiding in
the trenches there just doesn't matter
oh that's okay
shoot show / why not there it is
good night sweet prince why not
that was students nice and oh my god
there's Bridge edge I'm going this way
oh you can't hit between car
what got plenty of Health all right
we're playing loving look how big this
Schnabel is look at the Schnabel I don't
care if it's illegal for me to play with
this tank I want to kill its concern a
boat I'm all right
excuse me excuse me
this may think I know what I'm doing
that's this is my camp
this monkey you can run but you cannot
thank you can run but you come on come
on come on come on come on come on come
on come on come on come on what I'm
going in
Rilla I got him real damn well it's your
problem
this is the most swedish oh my god can
you stop Oh No
there's barely any damage there
Oh Oh penetration you can't hurt to me
I'm Swedish someone else took the kill I
penetrated I penetrated no fear that's
mine stop shooting Fiat he's mine game
is easy in fact I think they made this
game too easy okay
check out the world of tanked it's free
enter the code 3d pie you get 14 premium
days that is 2 weeks you get a premium
tank the British Excelsior 250,000 get
credit bro then you also get lung
sincere Swedish peralta you get the
Soviets to your 8 and you get Tiger
three-on-one check it out
have fun this game is historically
accurate smash like 4 PP